hi everyone I'm Matt sax we're the
co-founders CEO of luminary and this is
my partner Lauren and and us along with
three others started luminary in January
of 2018 we launched the business last
month and it's been it's been nothing if
not exciting and we're really honored
and privileged to be here thank you all
for having us and we're looking forward
to going through with you when we first
got asked to come here I think Lauren
and I looked each other and we're kind
of shocked and surprised honestly we
looked at the list of people who spoke
in this group before and you know we
just signed our names on a wall back
there and you know it's Harrison Ford
and Jack Dorsey and we're a month into
our journey and so you know in a lot of
ways we feel like you know no idea where
this goes and if we get to those levels
but but excited to share with you guys
what we've learned over the past 18
months and what we've learned being one
month in and I think because we are so
early in the journey we actually think
there's some interesting things that we
can share that maybe are different than
once you've gotten you know to the peak
or you've made more substantial progress
more you know sort of learnings from the
ground and from on the path so given
that a number of you may not have heard
of luminary before we were booked to
come here today we wanted to actually
spend some time getting a high-level
overview of the business
what is luminary talk a little bit about
our mission and sort of why we're doing
what we're doing and and then go through
some of the key learnings that we've had
over the past you know since starting
the business when we think about you
know sort of what we've learned and and
the experience we've had so far there's
a couple key notes that we want to hit
and talk through with you one is you
know the idea of looking for opportunity
wherever you are and wherever you have
the chance to see it for Lauren and for
me I think the path to starting a
business was not a linear one and it
really was made possible by
being different places in our career and
seeing an opportunity that was maybe
five degrees to the right or five
degrees to the left of where we were
supposed to be looking and then you know
running through those those doors when
we saw them hope that they were open to
and this is something Lauren will spend
a lot of time on is the importance of
building a great team I'm sure every
week in this class when people come in
they talk about that but you know they
that's because it's true and and so when
Lauren and I partnered and decided to
make people ops in the talent function
part of the co-founding team a luminary
it was really in pursuit of knowing how
important of a function that could be
for growing and scaling a business
quickly I think the third thing we want
to touch on is how to manage and how to
communicate through complex situations
you know complexity I actually think
often presents really great opportunity
and that's something we will talk about
today is sometimes when things are
misunderstood when things are
challenging to explain that's actually
where the opportunity lies but in order
to capture that opportunity you have to
be able to communicate very succinctly
very clearly and that's an area where I
think we as a business at times have
done well and another times have had
some missteps and so we want to talk
about those with all of you and sort of
what we've learned and and how we're
thinking about it going forward so
really excited to be here thank you
again and with that I'm going to turn it
over to Lauren to give an overview of of
what luminary is and go from there hi
everyone
I am Lauren Perkins as matt said I'm on
the cofounders of luminary and I'm also
the head of talent to echo Matt we truly
are really thankful for the invitation
to be here and we hope that you can pick
up something from what we learned last
year and a half and we're specifically
in the last month that you can bring
with you as you evaluate your next job
or potentially starting a business
yourself so what does head of talent
that means I run a function internally
that we call people ops that is you can
think of it like a marketing team but
the CMOS job is to find consumers and
keep them on our platform our job is to
identify great talent and
retain them so that starts with planning
figure out what roles we need sourcing
recruiting finding people from all
different backgrounds that can fit the
role budgeting salaries all the way to
promotions performance cultural and
overall employee workforce health we're
curious how many people in this group
listen to podcasts regularly how many of
you had heard of luminary before it was
announced that Matt and I would be here
today how many of you have downloaded
the app and started interacting with
some of the content pretty good we have
a good sales opportunity they do a good
job today hopefully all we subscribers
soon
so what luminary the product is is two
main pieces the first is an absolutely
free podcast app it is a way to find and
listen to hundreds of thousands of
podcasts basically like a search engine
there's a directory online to public
directory called the RSS feed
that's where get the content from the
creators of those podcasts can choose to
monetize their content with ads that has
nothing to do with our business that is
their choice we pipe it in hopefully we
can find more listenership for them and
we can provide great content to anyone
for free the way we monetize a business
is the second part of the app it is an
exclusive content network with over 40
shows these are some of our creator
partners it's the quality of these shows
that really differentiates us in the
market we have over 1,000 hours of
exclusive content you can find it on
luminary ad-free we're really proud of
our partners it's a there's a lot of
different content different types of
voices different formats different
genres we think there's something there
for everyone but the content is really
the core to our business so if you
thinking about the people the product
the content and then lastly the fourth
component of our overall business is the
brand so what the market marketing team
is doing to make all of
you aware of luminary what the service
is what the offering is what the value
proposition is is how we think of our
company so you know Lauren mentioned a
couple core parts of the business for us
it really starts and stops with the
content that that is on the luminary
premium service and our content partners
in our content network podcasting offers
incredible content you know you saw from
the number of hands that went up in this
room and we asked how many listeners
there are it's really an incredible
medium and and it offers so many
different things I think the word that
you hear most frequently when people
talk about why they love either being a
podcast or listening to podcasts is
intimacy right a connection between the
host and the creator something about ear
pods or air headphones being in your in
your ears almost sounds like a voice you
know in your head having a interpersonal
dialogue with you there's a real
connection between the host and the
creator which has defined the space for
for the past you know 15 years since
podcasting has been around that's why we
got into this that's why we decided we
wanted to start luminary so for me
started as a podcast listener you know
shows like Bill Simmons shows like
recode media with Peter Kafka roomette I
remember you know where I was when I
listened to the first episode of slow
burn which is a creator named Leon
neethu who's actually doing a note new
show with us and in he went he told a
eight hour deep dive investigative
report on Watergate telling stories that
you know you hadn't hadn't been told
their surface before whether it was
Martha Mitchell you know or or the
standoff between the FBI and building
security when they were trying to find
get get through the files on what
actually happened then and to me it was
just an incredible example of how and
why podcasting is so special because it
gives creators an opportunity to tell
stories in their their way you know the
low-cost formed nature of production
creates a lot of flexibility and
opportunity for creators to really
pursue unbridled creativity and go down
a path that you know isn't in their mind
and that they see and so that's why we
wanted to be able to be
in the space and that's what we want to
build a business around it's just great
premium podcast content lots of content
businesses out there lots of different
models and so before we started the
business we spent a lot of time thinking
about how we wanted to build it
what model we wanted to pursue and what
the right business model was for us to
support and invest in this amazing
content you know you think about a
business like Disney
that's an intellectual property business
at its core right they make amazing
content and they figure out how to
monetize it across categories whether
it's in TV shows or movies or amusement
parks or merchandise or now streaming
services you know businesses like HBO
Netflix subscription services and sort
of very pure play clear you know clear
and and single minded business models
others like maybe the New York Times or
Spotify both ad-supported and
subscription supported and then others
still purely ad supported like a
BuzzFeed or a Vox media and so we spent
a lot of time at the beginning of
starting the company debating what was
the right path and where we landed was
to try and embrace both of those models
but in a somewhat unique way so as
Lauren mentioned luminary offers a free
app anyone can use that app to listen to
publicly available content that content
is often ad supported although not
always and we actually have no economic
participation in that side of the
business so we are purely a pass-through
and people are listening to content that
is monetized elsewhere on our service
and then we have our subscription
service for premium content if you think
about a business like HBO you have to be
a subscriber in order to engage with HBO
at all Netflix as well right and so it
was it has been written or publicly
talked about luminary as the Netflix of
podcast luminaries attempt to be the
Netflix of podcasts we actually you know
don't say that internally and I think
that when we talked about communication
through four complex situations that's
one of the areas where there's been some
confusion and there's been some and you
know we probably could have done a
better job proactively communicating the
differences
we've always said as we want to be
synonymous with podcasting the same way
Netflix is synonymous with TV and film
and and but didn't call enough attention
to the differences in nuances in the
model so so what is the model and what
is luminaries business you know one
subscription is a great way to fund
content across categories so whether
it's print music TV and film
subscription has been a really
productive funding model for content for
you know decades and has driven a lot of
the growth in internet-based content
models over the last ten to fifteen
years to podcasting specifically in our
view at least had a real need for a
subscription model there are some
businesses in the space that attempted
to pursue a subscription model some that
do donation supported content but I
think in our opinion a primarily
primarily ad supported ecosystem when we
started had a real opportunity for a
subscription model to emerge and that
was something we were committed to and
believed in and wanted to pursue three
and this is a really important point we
don't believe it needs to be one or the
other it doesn't need to be only ads or
only subscription we think both of those
things can actually work harmoniously
together and that's why we've landed on
the model we did and then for
subscription really allows for the
investment in technology in the
investment in marketing to try to build
a holistic ecosystem you know
ad-supported content sometimes struggles
to invest in technology or marketing and
and we thought with a subscription
service and a consumer oriented business
you could really invest in those two
things which would help drive the space
forward so if anyone is bored at night
and wants a good bedtime read we wrote a
blog post try and explain it
medium says it's six minutes long so not
that bad and and and it really does
articulate sort of our vision for the
for the category what we're trying to do
but as mentioned at the beginning really
the core of our business is trying to
elevate podcasting for listeners and
creators for listeners to be a great
place to find amazing content and do
that both because of the quality of the
content on the network and the
technology that we offer helping them
discover new show
and for podcasters to be a place where
they can do their best work and they can
come and have you know sort of unbridled
creative freedom we'll sort of invest in
in them offer resources production
budgets and try to really help them you
know make their best show so that's the
that's the why they're sort of the the
what the how and the why given that
Lauren and I are early in the journey we
thought now it made sense to take a step
back sort of explain how we actually got
here and and some of the things we saw
in terms of opportunities that led us to
starting this business and so Lauren you
know lets you jump in and run through
your background okay
so the theme here is look for
opportunity wherever you are matt
mentioned this earlier but when we
started thinking about how matt was
thinking early on about building the
business and however think about where
we got how we got to where we are it's
not a linear path at all I graduated
from the University of Virginia with a
degree in civil and environmental
engineering after school I got a job at
one of the biggest general contractors
in the world I was working at Turner
Construction I was an assistant
superintendent on a very rewarding
project I was working an ambulatory care
center for the Children's Hospital of
Philadelphia I was 20 for me and a very
small team we're managing the work and
the schedules of anywhere from 200 to
800 people on site every day and I can't
overstate how much more these people
knew about building than I did the way I
was able to be successful in that job
was truly by building good relationships
communicating working on project
management skills and prioritization so
I loved that job but after a couple of
years I realized that a big company
isn't the right environment for me I
wanted the big company role because I
wanted to build those foundational
skills and I got that and I'm really
happy with that decision but I realized
that for a couple of years that while my
daily job was challenging it was one
trade for one project which was probably
one of
projects in Philly which was Turner's
and probably 50 cities and it's all over
the world I was in a very little
cross-functional insight I was a junior
employee at a massive company I wasn't
at the decision-making table I wasn't
even close to I don't know where the
table was so I wanted to be in the
position that I knew it was going on and
I could offer my skills my insight to
other parts of the company so I started
applying new jobs through a family
member my network I ended up in an
interview for a role in an executive
search firm I don't know if you all know
what that means I certainly did not know
what that meant at the first interview I
treated like a meet and greet I would
not recommend that as you go into
interviews this spring but what I found
out is that executive search is when you
hire a firm to come in work with the
founders a CEO sometimes investors to
identify one individual that will be a
leader for your company it's truly a
partnership it's a long process but
typically that person is someone that
brings their company to the next level
so what I got out of this job was I
learned the skills of recruiting I was
amazing I love that but on top of that I
got insight into tons of vc-backed
companies what their problems were their
pain points how we could solve them and
then me as a consultant I got to go out
into the ecosystem and try to find
people I could solve that problem and
talk to brilliant individuals every day
about what they did get to where they
were and how they could be effective in
that role and somehow I got to be the
decision-maker whether or not they got
to pick that call so it was an awesome
awesome job got me exactly where I
wanted to be I wasn't at the decision
table but I now knew it was I was on the
phone one tweak with them and that with
true I moved to New York started working
on searches for a number of vc-backed
companies many of them were in the new
enterprise associates portfolio that's
where Matt was an investor at the time
the two of us knew each other personally
we started get together pretty often
professionally to discuss what companies
were growing what talent was out there
the
challenges that high-growth companies
see and it was at one of these meetings
that Matt you know started telling about
luminary he pulled out a deck he'd
clearly thought through this create
literally created a deck had done user
research and we started talking about
you know how we could build out that
team it would look like and that's when
he changed a conversation he said you
know that's great we'll find a CTO but
I'm here to talk about you and I want
you to come found this company with me I
wanna start the company together so
that's how we got started
I don't know from your perspective there
was probably more going on before that I
got pulled into a happy hour one day why
don't you think so
so maybe to step back even before Lauren
and I started talking through the
luminary I went to University of
Pennsylvania I was a history major I had
absolutely no idea what I wanted to do
once I graduated I just knew I loved
history and I was really interested in a
number of my favorite podcasts or
history podcasts and loved you know
reading Philadelphia is a great city to
study history and and and you know that
was kind of all I knew when I got to
school was that's what I wanted to look
into history major figured politics kind
of close you read about a lot of
political history and and would go try
that out after my freshman summer I got
an internship in the White House intern
program worked in the Eisenhower
executive office building every day got
to go on two trips with the vice
president's advance team and and was
just an incredibly this was you know the
first Obama White House was incredibly
cool experience and incredibly not right
for me and after that decided was gonna
look elsewhere so went and got a job in
the sexiest field you could think of
distress credit investing when it worked
at an investment firm for the summer and
this was they asked me to look at the
newspaper industry shortly after the
financial crisis newspaper companies
were having hard phonate hard economic
times and and there was and their
opinion a lot of opportunity to invest
there I went to them at the end of the
summer and I said and I should caveat
this by saying over the past five or six
years I think that some of the newspaper
but he's in the us have done incredible
jobs adapting their business evolving to
the Internet you know doing really great
journalism in a reporting and in
upholding you know true values of
democracy and you know incredible to
deliver incredible value but at the time
in 2011 I basically said you guys should
not be investing in the newspaper
industry you should be investing in
Google because there is a direct inverse
correlation between Google size and the
value of this information that's being
distributed they didn't love that that
was not the right answer to the project
but it did very clearly inform me what I
wanted to do with my career and where I
wanted to go next which was to work in
technology and to work in a you know
with high-growth companies so from there
I was I was kind of hooked I started a
music streaming service with two friends
you know this was right as Spotify was
getting to the US this was before
SoundCloud had a mobile app sort of the
right place the right time and the
wholly wrong execution we had no idea
what we were doing but we we learned a
lot from there when to intern at a
venture capital firm called first round
capital love that job thought I wanted
to do that job later in my life but
thought that I wanted to go build a
skill set and so after I graduated went
to work at Goldman Sachs as an
investment banking analyst and really
just learn a financial analyst skill set
and dive really deep into into that
which I thought would repair me for you
know wherever I was going to go next
got back to venture capital about a year
after that and was working at nea which
was an incredible job investing in
early-stage and growth businesses a lot
of my time was consumer internet focused
we worked with incredible companies and
founders we worked with jet comm we
worked with Casper mattress we worked
with you know goop we worked with just a
buzz feed a long list of internet-based
businesses and I couldn't you know be
have learned more and had a better
experience there as a podcast fan I got
very excited about trying to find an
investment in the podcast space and
ultimately we concluded you know the
company that we wanted to invest in
didn't exist
but there was a great opportunity to go
build it and so again I think you know
the second time in in my experience once
when I was supposed to be looking in the
newspaper industry and got excited about
technology
this time supposed to be looking for
investments and got excited about
building something that you know looking
for opportunity wherever you are really
rang true and and these were
opportunities that were you know five
degrees to the right or five degrees to
the left of of what I was tasked with
and and had the luck to you know really
be able to pick my head up and see where
I wanted to go and what I wanted to
drive so why podcasting why build a
business in the category this is today
today were you know Spotify has invested
about five hundred million dollars into
podcasting I Heart Radio talks about
beating one of the leading podcast
companies as far as how they're
describing themselves the podcast market
is big and growing and very exciting
today two to three years ago people
didn't necessarily have that perspective
I think they thought of it as kind of
niche it's kind of off to the side it's
not the same type of content as TV it's
not the same type of content as
publishing but but knowing sort of what
I knew as a fan and and having the
interactions I did with my friends who
all loved the space you knew the content
was special and as the last couple years
have gone on it's become very clear that
podcast is a big deal 62 million people
today listen every week on average they
listen for about an hour a day and and
144 million people in America have
listened to a podcast it's growing
really rapidly the challenge with
podcasting from an investor perspective
was that the economic model was lagging
the consumer adoption and the consumer
engagement so what this chart shows here
the average hour of listening from a
podcast listener generates two cents of
revenue you look at radio Spotify and
satar's radio streaming and satellite
radio and it's significantly more
our revenue then in the podcast space
for a very similar type of content when
we were looking at investing in the
space we tried to figure out why that is
and in our business which we mentioned
before is really about great podcast
content and how to build a business and
monetize around it and so we landed on
the subscription model because due to
this podcast ad rates are actually
pretty good you know $35 CPM which is a
cost per thousand impressions of an ad
compared to $13 on radio but the ad load
in podcast is very low three minutes of
ads per hour on average radios about 18
so in order for podcasting to catch up
to these other businesses either you had
to introduce a new model and you had to
deduce a new revenue stream or add load
had to go from 3 minutes per hour up
significantly which would have been a
negative for the user and ultimately
would have led to the cost per ads
coming down similar to radio we got very
excited about the opportunity to build a
subscription business in the space and
and as Lauren mentioned did some
extensive research about the viability
of a subscription business and
ultimately came to the conclusion after
talking to thousands of users thousands
of listeners that you know podcast
content was no different than TV or film
or music or publishing and that if you
had great premium content there was an
audience that would pay for it there was
an appetite to pay and so we set out to
build a business we found a luminary in
January of 18 and in the fall of 2017 is
when I went to Lauren I said you know
this feels like a really big opportunity
we've been able to raise some capital
from a few different investment firms
including my old firm to go after it and
and it's very clear to me that you know
the most important thing that we're
gonna need to do is hire a great team
and move really fast and as a result you
know having a head of talent a a partner
who's running the people operations
function on the co-founding team was
really important to me
we were really clearly aligned on that
vision and and so we started going so
now
I think Lauren's gonna talk through a
little bit the impact that that's had on
our business today yeah I think what
Matt lays it out like that it is very
obvious why having a recruiter and
someone responsible for the overall
health of the workforce early on can add
value and when you read blobs or posts
or interviews with founders and CEOs so
many of them say that they spend 90% of
their time or more on recruiting and
hiring that is so puzzling to us because
it's very uncommon to have a talent
professional as a co-founder today in
the vc-backed world we think that will
change our investors feel like it's been
a good value add but internally it's
been extremely successful we in about a
year built a company that has about 70
people almost every single one of our
employees is outperforming our
expectations for their role and we have
an incredibly high retention rate so we
think it was a good move for this class
and personally for me though I think
what could be a challenge for you one
day is figuring out if you want to quit
your job or if you want to take this
risk and start a company with someone
and to me this was one of a couple of
things that stood out as a true
differentiator between the the group we
were co-founding with and other
companies I've seen in the past I knew
that by hiring this person they were
very forward-thinking about people and
truly investing in that asset I knew
that as an employee of this company that
I would have the support that I need but
also as the person leading this function
I would have the investment from the
executive team that the function
deserves so something to think about
when you're potentially evaluating
potential co-founders or bosses a second
part of that another thing that was
really influential in making the
decision to come on board and leave like
I said a lovely job in executive search
was the fact that every one of our
co-founders wanted to work through a
values dock from the beginning we
to make sure that the values were
important to every single person that we
were actually aligned and what we were
building these are our five values we
value diversity accountability
excellence doing what is right in
progress we decided early on that these
values would govern every decision that
we would make that potentially could
affect our consumers our co-workers or
creators and that has been a huge asset
to attracting retaining talent but it's
not just on the employee side it's
really been a differentiator when going
out to the content market and asking
partners to trust us in what we're
building and why it can be different and
to come on our platform
you know this content that is your
livelihood and a lot of times it's your
baby to work with us exclusively you
know six months before the products even
launched so that was a big part of that
if you are considering co-founding
company I urge you to go through this
exercise very early on before you have
problems it might not be that important
but when you start to scale and you're
starting to make quick judgment calls
having these to fall back on is really
has been huge for us so culture values
two major components of the people up
function at luminary the other the third
major focus is recruiting we thought
today it would be more interesting
instead of talking about our recruitment
process how we find it identified
candidates that are right for our
company to spin it actually and maybe
provide some insight into some
straightforward but subtle differences
between interview processes that might
allow you to figure out what company is
right for you or potentially dodge'
company that isn't correct or isn't the
right fit the first one is clearly
defined role in qualifications hopefully
there's a job spec for any role you're
applying to when a company's moving as
quickly as we are and a lot of companies
are that is not always a case you
can verify this by making sure that
every person you meet for your interview
panel can clearly articulate the what
and the why of this role that should be
pretty much consistent across that slate
of individuals if they can't that can be
a sign that the company isn't organized
or they aren't defining roles internally
it could be they're not being
transparent or performance and you could
be potentially taking responsibilities
from someone that doesn't know there's a
lot of problems that can arise if you
come into a company for a specific role
and no one knows what it is so make sure
you're clear on that second and
organized and defined interview process
this is something that our team takes a
lot of pride in we launched just a month
ago but we've been interviewing people
for 13 months it was our first
interaction with any individual in a lot
of cases it was so as you know first
impressions really matter right so are
the people that you're interacting with
treating you literally just being
courteous and professional are they
following back with you following up
with you in a reasonable amount of time
did they invest the time and the
resources in creating a seamless
interview process it doesn't have to be
perfect but the processes that their
team builds that you interact with our
indication of the processes throughout
the company it's it's one small thing
that a lot of companies might put to the
side but overall if you're a company
that takes people seriously this is
something you're investing in early and
then lastly incorporating values and
work samples into the interview process
so this is something we do on every
on-site it might not be clear if an
interviewer is asking you a question
that they're trying to determine the
alignment between your values and the
company values it can be a behavioral
question or you know something more
vague but if you walk out of an
interview or you get an offer and you
don't feel like your skill set was truly
vetted and that your values were at
least through conversations aligned with
the company's
values then you should take that as a
flag in my opinion you can think of it
this way getting the job is great right
you feel happy it's you did a great job
all through school way to get this job
that's great come into the company that
team that hired you they're making
decisions across the board if they you
know hide high-level conversations with
you when they're going in vetting out
agencies or investors or BD partnerships
if they are not capable or not willing
to do the proper level of due diligence
there's going to be massive business
implications from that so take their
decision-making process into account as
a model for how they make decisions
across the organization all of this
being said these are nuances there's not
a single thing that we haven't done in
our interview process that breaks one of
these rules companies move fast but it
is these little differences that may
cause you to ask more questions or try
to get more information so I think for
the rest of the time before we take some
questions we want to go through a couple
of things you know one this idea that
complex stories complex opportunities
require really clear communication we
have a very good example of to go
through on that and then to to talk
about the the opportunity that you
sometimes or often find in these complex
situations so you know as Lauren and I
have gone through we had a clear vision
for what we wanted to do with luminary
we have a great network of content
creators we put together lauren and
built out a great team of you know 70
people in a short amount of time we even
got a great new york times story
announcing that our company was
launching and talking about our content
network on april 23rd we launched and
these are some of the headlines that we
got coming out of that so not exactly
what you dream of when you think about
launching your company and getting
covered by the press the one saying
Apple luminary and Spotify and the pilot
that one's not bad
good company the others not so good so
what happened and and we've spent a lot
of time you know reflecting and thinking
about what happened and what could we
learn and what do we do different going
forward there's a couple of things here
that we'll talk about in some detail
that are tactical and actual specific
instances but I think at a higher level
there's two things that we've really
zoned in on one you know proactively and
clearly clearly and succinctly
communicate what you're doing to all
stakeholders not to some not to the
people you've had the time to get in
touch with but to everyone and so that
concept of clear communication keeps
coming up and is something that you know
really important into when you're moving
really fast sometimes you actually have
to slow down so you can go faster
sometimes you have to take a breath look
around understand where you're at and
then accelerate from there because just
constantly moving to the next item in
the next issue to solve in the next
thing on your agenda you don't get
always the proper time to think to
understand you know the full context of
the conversations you're having and then
to make the most informed decisions so
let's go through this the tweet so not
sure if anyone in here has seen a red my
guess would be you have the first tweet
that came from our company social media
account was a tweet that was essentially
negative on the ad market it it was
negative on podcasting and podcasts you
know as we discussed earlier as we wrote
in our blog post that is no in no way
shape or form our belief we actually
built a model that tries to embrace both
subscription and ad-supported content
and it was a it was a mistake right it
was just a miss
it was going too fast it was not having
the right processes in place to approve
something before it came out from an
official company account and and it was
a mistake
we took the tweet down we issued two
sort of explanations but we didn't
really own it an issue an apology and
say you know raise our hand and say my
bad for a couple weeks after and and I
think once we did that and once we just
said you know what we messed that up
that was a mistake
we actually were able to move the
conversation away from and people
understood so an interesting lesson
there and one sometimes you got to go
slow to go fast and sort of understand
what you're doing have the right
processes in place very similar a lot of
what Lauren talked through on the people
outside and too when you do make a
mistake which in a start-up you were
going to do every day sometimes you just
have to own it and raise your hand and
say that was a mistake and we'll you
know do better the next time
the second piece that was that came up
through our lodge is a conversation
around licensing a podcast content and
where does podcast content live
historically the space has been
unlicensed contents been widely
distributed and because there was an
economic model where distribution equals
impressions equals ad revenue everyone
wanted their content on pretty much
every service but the space is growing
up our entire business is about part of
the space growing up and and you know
our entire business is similarly about
the value of podcast content and so if
you're a Content owner a Content
distributor who values what you are
creating you know you may not want your
content on all platforms and you may
want to pick and choose where it is
similar to how you know things work in
the video world today you have some
shows that are only on HBO some that are
only on Showtime some that are only on
Netflix some that are on multiple of
those services and so there's a
licensing conversation that is
essentially in our view podcasting and
entering adolescence or adulthood I
don't know you know exactly where where
you draw the line on that but the space
is maturing and and so there was a
pretty interesting conversation in the
space about where and why content will
live where it does the third piece is on
technology and really for us actually
how our technology appeared to the
outside world not what we were doing
internally this again comes back to
communication so so we chose a
technology architecture that looked a
certain way what was actually happening
underneath and inside the company was
something different but we didn't do a
good enough job proactively going out to
the world and saying here's
we're doing here's why we're using this
sort of the this this methodology to
access your your podcast content here's
how the data flows and because we didn't
go out and clearly communicate we woke
up one morning at 4 a.m. there's a tweet
that said I think I think luminary is
doing this but by the time we got on the
office at 7:00 it was sort of widely
understood that that was what we were
doing it was about the concept of
caching and re hosting content we were
not doing that but we hadn't proactively
explained that and we had made some
technology architecture choices that
made it possible for people to imply
that and so we spent the next couple
days
one explaining that publicly through the
press and through social media to
getting on the phone with content
publishers and owners in the space large
technology players in the space the
hosting providers and explaining what we
were doing and you know we had gotten a
sort of clean bill Health sign off and
made progress to write any of the issues
that we had very quickly but because we
weren't proactive enough about our
communication strategy the narrative had
sort of picked up on itself and it took
us a little bit longer to win that back
we actually feel like now we've done a
really good job of going out explaining
what we were doing what we are now doing
and doing that proactively but it did
take you know some time and and some
pain to to get the message out there and
get it out there clearly so so going
forward what does it mean and what do
you do I think one you communicate
proactively to every time we make a
decision we need to really think about
all of the stakeholders it impacts not
just consumers not just the creators
making shows for luminary premium but
every constituent in the market and make
sure that they fully understand what
we're doing and though that might mean
sometimes you have to go a little slower
you have to you know reach out and do
your calls and your emails or speak at a
conference and really articulate what
you what you are doing to the market but
going slower and taking that step back
gives you the opportunity to actually go
faster and
and go faster in the long run so to wrap
it up and then we'll take questions like
you know this feels this concept of
complicated stories possessing great
opportunity really feel like that
articulates kind of where we are today
in our journey you know I think the goal
and when you really know you're in the
right place is when you can take a
complicated story break it down and
communicate it very simply think about
you know ride-sharing businesses and how
complicated and crazy the idea that you
were gonna get in the back of someone's
car who was a total stranger to go to
the airport and sometimes another
stranger was going to get in the back of
that car with you you were gonna have a
conversation and never see that person
again before that became you know sort
of commonplace and widely understood
that was confusing and complicated but
once it's understood is often when you
know it is often when you lose the
chance to actually create opportunity
and to build something new when it is
kind of messy when people don't fully
understand what's going on and when
there's you know inconsistencies and and
things that sort of don't make sense
that's when we feel like you have the
best opportunity which is the space we
saw podcasting at a couple years ago we
think it's still very much there today
and we think that as the space becomes
more defined and understood over the
next few years that's when we'll try to
build our business and sort of put order
to the chaos creating that opportunity
that we've seen
you